yesterday we told you about a tragic
situation in West Texas that left one
Border Patrol agent dead and another
critically injured according to border
patrol union officials the agents were
attacked by rocks with illegal ill alien
throwing them but over on CNN they're
introducing other theories several Texas
officials refer to some kind of attack
on these two agents but the local
sheriff told The Dallas Morning News
quote the injuries to Martinez after
talking to his doctors were consistent
with a fall very consistent with a fall
joining us now are two men with insider
knowledge of the situation Brandon Judd
is the president of the National Border
Patrol Council and he joins us from
Bozeman Montana and from McAllen Texas
is Chris Cabrera a spokesman for the
National Border Patrol Council Chris I
want to talk to you first because when I
heard about this tragic incident of
course I think about Brian Terry I think
about so many of the Border Patrol
agents over the years who've lost their
lives protecting our border very
dangerous situation but it was
understood first that there were
multiple head injuries tell us about why
that theory bandied about on CNN may not
be accurate well if you look from where
it's believed that the agents were
attacked our guest at CNN says where
they fell from the area around it it's a
culvert it's not a ravine it's about
nine feet off the ground
Chris yeah we have piers of it which
we're gonna show as you're speaking so
go ahead you know it's it's a sandy dirt
like surface and for as far as the
ground goes and if somebody fell there I
I mean it's nine feet off the ground is
it possible that they could have died
from that it's possible but but it's
highly unlikely the way they make this
sound is that that he went down some
deep ravine and that's just not the case
it was a culvert on the side of the road
these agents know that culverts there
it's right off of i-10 it's not like
that took them
by surprised and then for both agents to
be you know struck or struck in the same
manner it's just it's it's highly
unlikely and I don't understand if if it
had been an accident why is it taking
four days three and a half days for them
to figure out or rule out that it's an
accident on top of that they're offering
$25,000 reward to the FBI if it's an
accident who would possibly be able to
collect that reward that tells you that
that Sheriff doesn't know what I hate to
be rude but he doesn't really know what
he's talking about Brandon let's go to
you on this clearly if this had been an
attack by some type of cartel affiliated
group of individuals illegal immigrants
or not that would of course bolster the
president's argument that we need real
border security we need to empower the
Border Patrol we need more of them and
we need a wall if it's an accident well
it just
either drove off into that culvert which
doesn't seem very tall to me sandy they
fell off and just hit their head and
died then that doesn't really add to the
argument of the wall does it it doesn't
and if you look at it dangerous borders
are the reality today and that's the
that's what we deal with on a daily
basis but if you look at all the facts
surrounding this this particular
incident this agent was out there
specifically looking for what we call
foot seiner footprints in the ground he
found some he radioed it in he said that
this is good foot sign he himself got
out on foot and he started to follow
these footprints in the in the dirt up
to an area if I could paint a picture
for your your viewers if they're playing
hide and seek if you're the one that's
hiding you're gonna see the person
that's coming looking for you especially
if they have a flat flashlight in hand
these individuals that were hiding they
were able to attack these agents and
they were able to take the agents out
very very common it could be it could
happen to any agent at any time I mean I
can tell you from my own perspective as
a k-9 handler I arrested 57 illegal
aliens by myself with my k-9 partner
that situation could have gone bad very
very quickly and in this particular case
it did go bad and that's because we have
dangerous borders and Chris back to you
on this I think most Americans watching
this tonight they hear about the border
but if they don't live you know and
they're where you live McAllen or El
Paso they don't really get what it's
like it's dangerous for property owners
it's dangerous for residents it affects
morale of Border Patrol agents when they
don't feel like they're getting the
support or a credibility that they
deserve and this spills over into the
country at large and President Trump is
trying to do something about this
Congress continues to drag its feet
continues yeah you know what people need
to understand people that don't live
here on the border they need to
understand how it affects them the the
rest of the country as a whole for
instance these folks that are coming
through a lot of people come through
this area a great number of people come
through this area the thing is the
majority of them don't stay here they're
they're funneling into the rest of the
country the Atlanta's the Houston's New
York's the middle America and a 20% of
the people we encounter have criminal
history and it's just it's it's it's an
ongoing thing and at some point we need
to get serious about this border
security we need the infrastructure we
need the manpower but more than anything
we need that political will to get it
done because without that we're just
going to continue spinning our wheels
and incidents like this are gonna
continue to happen incidents like the
Kate Steinle murder gonna happen it's
just it's just an ongoing thing well
it's needles in a haystack and meanwhile
we're putting the lives of good men and
women in the Border Patrol in jeopardy
and and most of time there's no reason
for it if we actually have a secure
border thank you thank you to both of
you for your service to this country